washington londres paris pékin moscou
est aussi montréal il a passé les 40
dernières années à parcourir la planète
pour nous offrir son regard un regard
unique sur le monde
c'est un témoin privilégié des
événements marquants qui ont forgé
l'histoire on n'a qu'à penser à la chute
du mur de berlin il était là présent et
le journaliste correspondante de radio
canada raymond st-pierre bâtir sa
révérence après ses belles années à
radio-canada pour nous il est à mes
côtés bonsoir aimons soient écoutés on
vous a rendu un hommage presque surprise
cet après-midi sur les hanches avec
alexis de l'antenne ou si on avait la
chair de plus de 4
s'arrêtant dans les autres salles de
nouvelles les échos dans les chaumières
aussi aujourd'hui je l'écris l'adresse
la plus grosse la plus la meilleure
boîte d'information pays puis je pense
que on va dresser pour notre pays il
faut continuer à se battre pour
l'indépendance d'information la phase
d'information et des vraies nouvelles
l'uci merci c'est notre travail mais
vous le faites bien merci beaucoup
d'émotion raymond ben oui je vais au nez
dedans m'attendais pas à ça on est
concentré dans notes entrevues à coups
mais qu'est ce que ça fait de
d'accueillir cet hommage up pour avoir
d'enfant traduit ce qui se passait dans
le monde pendant 40 ans ce n'est pas
rien 40 ans c'est les grands chapitres
de notre histoire moderne
oui mais ils souvent quand on est loin
comme ça on n'est pas tellement
conscients de l'impact qu'on a sur place
ici autant dans la salle des nouvelles
d'ailleurs que chez les gens parce que
souvent on fait des choses bean games
envahiront sélections on est souvent la
cour sous les ors de tomber décalage
horaire le fameux décalage horaire de
vous ruiner la vie alors là pas à peu
près moscou par exemple c'est pas facile
pékin non plus aux 12 heures de décalage
donc souvent parce que la machine la
roue tourne et où les gens n'ont pas le
temps ou pas l'occasion de nous dire
exactement c'est quoi la réaction au
pays
comment les gens dans la salle ont réagi
et tout ça et les gens pas tout le temps
d'écrire alors si c'est difficile à
distance d'avoir vraiment à 100% de la
halle une idée de la réaction des gens
sur place et quatre votes et
d'événements comme se déroule la gt j'ai
compté dans la vie des gens à aimer ça
pourquoi d'après vous c'est important
d'avoir notre regard de quelqu'un et
10,6 sur le monde pourquoi c'est
important je pense que c'est vraiment
que nous on est différent le canada
c'est différent le québec si différents
on n'a pas envahi personnes on a
colonisé personne sauf le lot où on se
trouve
quand on débarque dans bien des parties
du monde que ce soit en afrique se
reproche rien et tous les gens nous
parlent différemment de ce qui parle aux
français ce qu'ils peuvent ou américains
ou britanniques et tous on est
complètement différent et le canada même
s'il ya eu à certaines années des
problèmes et d'image du canada en
général ont encore une excellente image
et déjà nous nous ne nous aime beaucoup
en chine vous êtes encore aujourd'hui
des enfants de 3 4 ans qui apprennent le
poème normand béthune oui le docteur qui
est allé faire la longue marche avec
baho de séton alors vous dites vous
sortez de pékin vous allez au milieu de
nulle part des gens quand même pas l'eau
courante ou qui ont des problèmes ou les
précités ici et là et vous dites que
vous êtes canadiens tout de suite les
enfants vous vous admirer tout et je
pense que ce n'est pas l'image de la
perception du canada bien d'autres
endroits au canada en aoât ailleurs en
europe et ailleurs dans le monde
vous avez vu le monde changer vous avez
est au coeur de conflits lorsque vous
avez couvert les troubles en irlande
parce que l'irlande revient d'actuaire
dans l'actualité aujourd'hui avec à la
faveur du bric site ont créé une
frontière absolue entre l'irlande du
nord et la république d'irlande
c'est là vous avez dit que vous avez vu
l'enfer pour la première fois vous étiez
à citer des funérailles ils sont issus
autour de vous pourquoi ces seuils
la bd des agents secrets britanniques
qui étaient des membres de l'iran dans
le groupe terroriste de grands qu'il
était à gibraltar voisin de l'espagne
territoire d'espagne en vies humaines
par d'autres britanniques voyaient de
l'espagne pouvait atteindre 0 scodi et
il avait battu de trois membres de
l'irak et l appui bon après il ya eu les
funérailles et en irlande du nord et
nous on suivait de londres à l'époque on
suivait régulièrement ce qui se passait
en irlande du nord
un conflit qui sont impossibles à
résoudre qui semblait interminable plus
jamais pouvoir se régler et c'est encore
pire ce jour là parce que justement
taillon s'est installé là tous les
journalistes le long des fausses
les trois forces pour où ils allaient
enterrer les lits 3 qui avait été abattu
à gibraltar et leader de l'ira ou de
chine freine la branche politique des
groupes de ces groupes là était là
devant nous et il ya un militant la
orangistes qui est arrivé vraiment
déséquilibré parce que il y avait un sac
plein de grenades et des armes et s'est
mis à danser grenade vers nous donc vers
les fosses dans les lieder de de chine
fin à l'époque qui aurait pu très bien
ils m'ont humour y eut des morts dans
cette attaque et c'est très mal on était
en plein enclin à l'endroit où ça s'est
passé c'était vraiment il va s'en
trouver entre l étranger ça montrait
combien ce conflit là que s'était
éternisée avait rendu un paquet de gens
complètement déboussolé extrémistes
incapable d'imaginer une autre vie que
celle là donc imaginez un monde en paix
tout c'est pour ça que c'est
décourageant de couvrir de dossiers là
alors de ses découragements jusqu'à la
chute du mur de berlin
vous étiez là assez dans ce point de
presse historique aussi parce que paris
a annoncé l'ouverture du mur ces
services qui le porte parole officiel du
parti communiste à l'époque c'est
important les réunions du parti
le monde se remette en question à
l'époque et lui arrivait de vacances y
ont reçu seulement après donc réduit il
ya plus de communiqué
il se met conférence de presse fin
d'après midi tout le monde arabe de
partir parce qu'il fallait nourrir
foires franches et checkpoint charlie
faut faire fouiller loto et tout c'est
très très très long et rentrer à berlin
ouest pour faire notre de monter notre
reportage donc on était tous très près
cible à la fin comme presque par erreur
il dit bon oui les gens à une question
qu'on pose est ce que les gens vont
pouvoir avoir des visas des gens de
l'est pour voyager parce qu'il est plein
de jeunes qui quittait bernès
l'allemagne de l'est ce qui allait dans
les pays voisins des qui contournait
donc l'allemagne de l'est et qui
revenait à berlin ouest ou à l'allemagne
de l'ouest
à l'époque et on a découvert ça pendant
des mois on se demandait bon est ce que
une fois pour toutes on traitera les
citoyens de l'est comme des adultes et
qu'ils auront le droit de voyager comme
des gens du reste du monde et lui avait
dit oui comme ça au web en indiquant
votre l'a immédiatement alors que
c'était pas ça du tout vraiment c'est
une question de mois puis même le le
vrai communiqué était assez vague et
tout ça mais nous même aujourd'hui on
n'y croyait pas donc on est à la fin de
la conférence de presse on est à
l'étroit quatre journalistes encore le
voir et lui redemander les turcs eux
nous ont pensé que c'était peut-être une
erreur de traduction ce qui arrive
souvent dans notre métier il faut faire
toujours attention à ça et nous annoncer
ça et alors on ne traverse et chaque
fois que j'allais encore les jets d eau
surfer demandons aux gardes-frontière
s'ils savent que peut-être que ça va
s'ouvrir à exister un suspect puis des
gens pas très gentilles mais ça c'est
fait et bien c'est ça dans la soirée je
revenais à chaque heure aller voir si ça
bouge et ça bougeait avait de plus en
plus avec des têtes de l'autre côté de
chaque point car dd tête des centaines
des milliers plus aucun moment donné
même ses gardes frontières qui était si
violent qui était déjà tiré sur ceux qui
voulaient traverser clandestinement real
ouest bas ils sont obligés de laisser
les portes ouvertes les vannes se sont
ouvertes et ces gens là vraiment sûr
débarqué dans la nuit c'était la fête et
vous deviez être bouleversée mais dans
le bon sens ému de voir qu'est la
liberté finalement
et puis on se rendait compte que 6 à ce
symbole là pouvait tomber
il ya bien d'autres choses qu'elle est
tombée honnêtement on le sentait ce soir
là que c'était historique ce qui est en
train de se passer ce n'était pas juste
un mur qui tombaient c'était des esprits
qui s'ouvrait des gens qui remettent en
question le système communiste bloc
communiste qui représentait est-ce que
ce mur la représenter pendant des
décennies vraiment et même si tu as
d'autres de sentiments parce qu'il y
avait des gens de l'est qui avait
traversé l'histoire plaide me demandait
il nous demandait est ce que ce qu'ils
vont pas refermées 2006 refaire mais non
on est pris de l'autre côté qu'est ce
qui va nous arriver
moi je travaille moi j'ai une famille et
y avait encore une grande inquiétude
parce qu'on n'était pas sûr que c'était
pour toujours que ce mur là était tombé
là en terminant à voir ce que poutine
veut faire aujourd'hui parce que les
trente ans plus tard
est-ce que la russie veut devenir
aujourd'hui c'était votre dernière
assignation est ce que l'avenir vous
inquiète
ce qui est inquiétant c'est que monsieur
du côté américain mais se trompe semble
abandonner tout ce qu'il ya comme
organismes internationaux alliance est
tous à l'otan et qu'il semble remettre
en question les relations avec les
alliés et tout ça et pendant sa longue
mais vous voyez monsieur poutine par
exemple ou même mieux de chez jean ping
en chine cesana occupe des territoires
laissé vacant par le le nom enthousiasme
monsieur tron pour tout ce qui est
international lui visiblement veut faire
affaire avec un pays seulement vous
viennent pas tellement c'est des
regroupements les a calmés traiter des
machettes de libre échange avec
plusieurs personnes vous à payer un clic
et et sabin et on voit que monsieur
poutine par exemple la série très très
présent tester ces nouvelles armes laboy
commence à en vendre de plus en plus
dans le monde et est de plus en plus
présent au proche orient on va monsieur
netanyahou d'israël débarqué de plus en
plus régulièrement moscou capte des
grandes décisions qui s'en viennent mes
grands événements ou d'aider des étapes
importantes au niveau diplomatique même
chose avec she jean ping on voit que de
plus en plus lui d avancer ses pions sur
le jeu d'échecs et développe des îles
dans la mer de chine est de plus en plus
présents dans mer de chine les
américains vendaient très très présent
et ne laissez pas l'expansion de la
chine à cet endroit là ce qui inquiète
ans en ce moment beaucoup les alliés des
etats-unis taïwan le japon la corée du
sud se demande ce qui se passe avec les
états unis parce que c'était leur garant
leur la force derrière eux qui les
amenait à avoir confiance dans le cadre
du montage et oui c'est ça que je trouve
qu'il y avait des endroits dans le monde
maintenant où les gens sont inquiets
devra les états unis démissionner de
cette force là de cette présence dans le
monde avant 5h à vous entendre on sait
que vous allez vous n'avez pas eu votre
dernier mot ce soir avec tout ceci on
sait que vous allez poursuivre la lutte
pour marcher à nouveau vous êtes atteint
d'une maladie rare
tout ce qu'on vous souhaite c'est la
santé j'allais nous manquer énormément
au beau jeu vous allez me révolte oui il
faut oui on va sans doute vous merci
beaucoup six premiers
ici raymond st-pierre radio canada à
moscou à londres à paris à bruxelles
checkpoint charlie nouvelle guerre des
boers on se reverra à la prochaine
d'ici là
x